[MUSIC PLAYING]
AMEET JANI: I am Ameet.
Good afternoon.
And I'm very excited today.
We have a special guest with us.
Just a quick question,
how many of you
have heard of BeyondCorp
or Context Aware?
Awesome.
Today, we are going to talk
about BeyondCorp or Context
Aware with an actual customer
who's actually deployed it.
This is Samuel.
Samuel is, in some
ways, my dream customer.
He wants to try
everything we do.
And in some ways, he's
my nightmare customer
because he breaks
everything that we do.
But that's a good thing.
So Samuel had two conditions
he had for talking.
One is this is not a
marketing presentation.
So he's going to tell you
what worked and didn't work.
And he really does do that.
And the second is that
he's going to talk
about being on another cloud.
And I said I think some
people here might be
on that same cloud, so it's OK.
Just out of curiosity,
how many people
are running a second
cloud, another cloud?
There's probably more.
You guys are just not saying.
So let me jump ahead.
Because there are
three speakers today,
they asked us to
introduce ourselves.
First is Sam.
Sam is the star of the show.
He's a security
engineer at Airbnb.
Next is Gagan.
Gagan works on cloud identity.
You're going to
talk about G Suite.
And then lastly is me.
Yes, that is really me.
I am on the Cloud Security team,
working on Identity-Aware Proxy
and [INAUDIBLE] products.
And so we'll talk about
all those as we go forward.
I'll give it to Sam.
I just want to highlight.
He is the star of the show.
We're going to let him
do most of the talking.
He's going to set
up the challenges.
Gagan and I will
quickly come on stage
and talk about how we have tools
to solve all those problems.
And then Samuel will
come back on stage
and tell you how he broke
those things to make them work.
So I'll leave it to you.
SAMUEL KEELEY: Cool.
Hey, everybody.
I'm Sam.
So, first, I just
want to [INAUDIBLE]
disclaimer that's at the
bottom of this slide.
I've been required to include
it because I am going to talk
about other clouds, about AWS.
So we've had a
lot of challenges.
But I just want
to go over briefly
what our corporate
architecture looks like.
It's probably very similar
to a lot of companies.
So we have users.
They have browsers.
They talk to a lot of hosted
SaaS apps, Slack, G Suite,
GitHub, tons of these apps.
But we also have a large
corporate infrastructure
of what we run ourselves.
So this is composed of
applications primarily running
on AWS, along with
some applications that
run in some local computer.
All of Airbnb.com runs on AWS.
But we have some
supporting services
that run with some
local compute, primarily
for some latency
reasons with SIP routing
and things like that.
But this is really what our
infrastructure looks like,
scaled down,
simplified, very basic.
But we've invested heavily
in end point instrumentation
and reporting.
We use tools like
Osquery from Facebook,
along with a tool that
we developed internally
called StreamAlert,
which runs in AWS Lambda
and analyzes the results
coming from Osquery suite.
We have a ton of
data that we look
at coming from our end points.
And then our users get to our
internal services through VPN
or 802.1X when they're
in an Airbnb office,
whether that's on a wired
connection or a wireless
connection.
If you're not in office, then
you're going to be using VPN.
So this is basically what our
infrastructure looks like.
There's a very strange
transition there.
So Airbnb was founded just a few
blocks away from here in SoMa
about 10 years ago.
And over the past
decade, has grown out
of just San Francisco.
And we now have offices
all around the world,
with thousands of
users supporting
our community of millions
of hosts and guests.
Our largest office is still
here in San Francisco,
but with all of
these offices, we
ended up building a
network for the users
to get to our services.
But this growth has presented
us with a constant challenge.
When you're just one
office, it's pretty easy
to get into your resources
that might be running
in AWS by whitelisting the IP
of your network or something
like that.
But as we've expanded,
that hasn't really worked.
So what we've
realized with that is
that the worst experiences
that our users have
are inconsistent ones.
So while you might
be in San Francisco
and be able to get everything,
if you go to Portland,
you haven't gone very far.
That's still a
large Airbnb office.
But you might not be able to
access everything that we have.
And the problem really just
gets worse the farther away
that you get from San Francisco.
Or it's gotten worse.
So a couple of years
ago, we started
a project called Work Anywhere.
And this comes out of
three kind of realizations.
The first is that securing
user networks is pretty hard,
at least doing it
in a way that's
user friendly and scalable.
So for us, 802.1X and VPN have
had a lot of edge cases where
they don't really work.
So in the case of 802.1X, when
we're expanding into a new
city, we might start off
in a managed service office
or something like that, where
we don't control the whole
network.
So it'll look like
an Airbnb office.
It'll feel like one.
But the network that they're
coming through isn't run by us.
It's really just an
internet connection.
So there are generally ways
that we could end up deploying
802.1X there through remote
access points or something like
that.
But generally,
getting those offices,
which are Airbnb offices, on
the network is not so easy.
So we end up having
those users who use VPN.
And then VPN has so
many edge cases, too,
where VPN falls over--
from users that are really far
away, from their VPN gateways,
or for users who are
flying in an airplane,
and they can't approve MFA,
or it's really hard for them
to get MFA working
when they're on VPN.
There's just so many edge cases,
where just securing the network
is hard.
Then what we've
realized, that is
latency makes things even worse.
We haven't been able to
defy physics quite yet.
So when we have these
offices all over the world,
and most of our applications
are running in US East
in AWS, as most companies
end up running things
in a single region
or a single country,
the latency to these apps
can just be really bad.
And we can't get you any
closer to that application.
But it's really easy
to make things worse.
So we've known about this
issue for a long time,
particularly for users
who are in Australia.
And if you are in Australia,
and say, you're in Sydney,
and you want to
connect to a VPN,
you're probably going to
connect to a VPN endpoint
that we have running in
Singapore because the one
that's closest to you.
But if you're in
Sydney and you're
connected to a VPN
gateway in Singapore,
that traffic is going
to route actually
way out of the way
to go to Singapore
and then come all the way back
to the east coast of the US.
It's over 50% farther
to go from Sydney
to Singapore all
the way to the US
than it is just to go
from Sydney to the US.
It might not be evident
without a globe,
but that's the reality.
And so latency becomes a
problem for even more users.
It becomes really obvious for
me when I'm on an airplane,
with the explosion of use of
satellite-based Wi-Fi on planes
that's going to outer space.
The best that you're
ever going to do there
is like 600 milliseconds.
But if you are on a flight
from Tokyo to Los Angeles,
your internet traffic
might actually
be bouncing off a few satellites
and coming out in Europe.
Now if you're on that flight
and you need to connect to VPN,
which gateway do you pick?
I mean, I would probably
pick the US one,
but that's actually the
wrong one for me to pick.
I should be connected
to the EU one.
And there's a lot
of VPN software
that can attempt to
make the right decision,
but we've just
realized that latency
gets bad for a lot of
users all the time.
And it's hard for users
to pick the right thing.
And then lastly is that users
expect to work anywhere.
If a user has a good
internet connection,
they know that they have a
good internet connection.
They can get to Gmail.
They can get to all these apps.
But their connectivity
to our internal apps
may not be so great.
If they're far
away from a gateway
or they're choosing
other ones, it's just not
working great for them.
So while a user
can theoretically
work from anywhere
today, they're
able to connect
to anything today.
If they're over VPN, they
can't really work anywhere
if it's a bad experience.
So we just believe that if
a user has a good internet
connection and a secure device,
they should be able to work.
So that's where our Work
Anywhere project came from.
And I think that's it from me.
Oh, one more slide.
So IT security at
Airbnb, so where
does security come into this?
So I'm just a security engineer.
I've been mostly talking about
networking and user-facing
stuff.
And this slide could have
a lot of things on it,
talking about what IT
security does at Airbnb.
But I think it's just really
exemplified in this one
photo of a security key.
So what IT security
tries to do at Airbnb
is find the best mix of
user experience and security
to propel both forward.
And I think that the
security key is really--
it's the holy grail for
what that should be.
So I'm proud to say
that we've deployed
over 10,000 of these
security keys at Airbnb.
And they the majority of
our multi-factor auths
are happening with these
for our internal users.
We no longer have any phone
call or SMS-based MFA,
which are obviously insecure.
But they were really just
a bad user experience.
So we've been able to
take MFA from being
a burden to something that
users have actually embraced
and enjoy to use.
And that's what
we've been trying
to do with Work Anywhere, is
propel both user experience
and security forward from
what we've had in the past.
Because there's a lot of ways
that you can have a great user
experience.
If we just wanted the
best user experience,
we just put all these apps
straight on the internet.
But that would obviously
be horrible for security.
So we've tried to
avoid to do that.
So with that, I'm going
to hand it off to Ameet.
AMEET JANI: Whoops, sorry.
Thank you.
He's coming back in a minute.
He'll talk about
what they actually
did to solve their problems.
But I did want to just
transition here for a moment.
All the things that
Samuel talked about
with security problems and
all those different things,
Google themselves,
we ourselves faced.
About eight to 10
years ago, there
was a well publicized thing of
state-sponsored hackers trying
to get into our network.
And so out of that, we
kind of changed our model
from a network-centric VPN model
to what we call the BeyondCorp
or zero trust model.
And so really, there's
three tenets of this model.
The first one is that you no
longer care about the network
that somebody's coming on.
You really, really care about
the context of that request.
And I'm not talking
about five or six things.
I'm talking about
120 different things.
And you're really thinking
about that on every request
to an application.
And that has a lot of
ramifications about how
you deploy these applications.
And we'll talk about that.
And the key is
that you should be
able to create granular
level access controls based
on if somebody's coming from
a corporate device or maybe
a known or trusted network
versus a non-corporate device.
Those people shouldn't be
shut out of being productive.
It just means that what they
get access to should be limited.
And we'll talk about
how we did that.
But this is exactly the model
that Google started to follow.
And so when we were putting
this model together,
we kind of hit on
a few key tenets.
I don't think there's anything
that's rocket science here,
but it's really important to
just walk through and kind of
understand all the components.
We can talk about all the
solutions for everybody.
The first one that we discovered
is very, very important
to understand the users.
I think that's obvious, but
there's a secondary portion
of that thing, which
is that you wanted
to understand user behavior.
If you log in from your
mother's house every Tuesday,
we shouldn't care that
it's your mother's house,
but we do want to know that
you have these patterns
and behaviors.
And if something starts
to fall out of the norm,
we can start to at
least create speed bumps
for users along the way.
The second part of
this is second factor.
And we'll touch on
that in a minute.
The other part of that whole
side of things that we found
is even if you trust a user,
you can attest very strongly
that the users who they say they
are, the device posture really,
really matters.
And I'll tell you
personally at Google,
I think we published
this in a white paper.
We have the team here.
You can ask them.
Something like 125
characteristics
about a request from
the device itself.
That's the two major components.
But then there's a whole
other context portion of this
that we really cared about.
And so we run a global
front end at Google,
which captures which IP address
you're running coming from.
We happen to know, we happen
to be constantly scanning
the internet to understand what
are good IP addresses, what
are VPN IP addresses, what are
state-sponsored IP addresses.
And we can start to
block access from those.
We also understand location, and
time of day, and session age.
All this stuff needs to be
collected at the request point
every single time.
But then the real
smarts for us came
in when we started
coming down the chain.
The rules engine
portion, we needed
to be able to create
human readable
and very easy to define rules
that took all those context
and took into account.
So you can apply them at, in
fact, an end point, right?
And so for us that
we wanted to protect
every piece of data
that's on the web for us,
we needed to protect.
That's not just HTTPS.
It is every type of piece
of data that's out there.
And so that was sort
of how we came up
with our BeyondCorp model.
And we put tooling in
place that revolves
around all of this stuff.
And then what happened
about two or three years ago
is we decided to
start productizing
these piece by piece.
And so what you're seeing
here is that really, the story
is more of a suite of solutions
than it is one singular
solution.
And I'll touch on
all of these things.
And the good news is you don't
need to adopt all or nothing.
There is a gradual
crawl, walk, run model
that we find ourselves at Google
using, we find customers using.
And so we can talk about
how that would work.
But just touching on
each for a moment here,
let's focus-- just turn
to these very quickly.
The first one is Cloud Identity.
Each one of you has
an identity system.
You don't need to use ours.
But we have one that's called
Cloud Identity, in fact,
where we manage
things like users,
groups, role information.
That's all very obvious.
They all sort of do that.
Now, imagine a world where
that identity system is locked
into your calendar, right?
So you understand
somebody's on vacation.
Somebody is in one
office and not another.
And a request is coming
in from somewhere strange.
You can start to kind of
create these sort of vectors.
The other thing is you
need a massive system that
does login abuse detection.
For us, the same system we
use for the enterprise side
is what we use on
the consumer side.
So we are getting good at
detecting fraudulent signals
because we do 1.2 billion
unique logins a month.
And so, we've gotten
very good at detecting
what those signals are.
Those are pretty obvious things.
The two other things I'll
just touch on briefly
that we find that a lot
of customers don't do
is session control.
I don't mean infinite
versus one hour.
I mean that every application
has a different use
case or a different footprint.
And you should be able to
create unique session length
controls for each of your
types of applications
that are out there.
The other one is MFA.
I'll say this.
MFA is better than
no MFA, but there
is a better story than OTP.
If you don't believe me,
just Bing OTP phishing.
Or you can Google it if you
want, CM vendor agnostic.
But no, in seriousness, the
OTP code have been phished.
You can do a simple
search for it and see.
What we use internally is
this idea of a FIDO U2F key.
Use any vendor.
It doesn't have to be us.
It can be anybody.
We find that this makes it--
if I say un-phish-able, you know
that's always a dangerous thing
to say.
So I'll say very, very
phishing resistant.
And no credentials
at Google have
been phished in
the last 18 months,
because we've moved
to this model.
The second portion of this--
so we talked about
Cloud identity.
The second portion is
actually the device itself.
Here we offer a few solutions.
The one I'm going to talk
about today, because I think
we have a broader story
that's in other sessions,
is what we call
Endpoint Verification.
Endpoint Verification is really
a simple Chrome browser-based
and soon other browsers,
preempting Samuel's complaints,
where we understand the
security posture of a device,
where we understand
the disc encryption,
the screen lock
version, the version
of software running
on the device,
secured boot, all these
different kinds of things.
Those are interesting.
I think what you'll find--
my friend Sanjay, Sanjay
Poonen, today on the stage
kind of announced.
He kind of pre-announced
this for us.
We are working with vendors.
So if you already have a mobile
device management or endpoint
management system, we
are working together
with this whole ecosystem to
feed their signals into this.
So you can say
Vendor X or Partner
Co is feeding those signals in.
I want to use that to make
access decisions for my Google
resources or resources on AWS.
You can certainly do that.
And the other thing
is you want to be
able to distinguish
between corp-issued devices
and non-corp-issued devices.
And so I think Gagan will give a
little bit of a preview of some
of what we're doing there.
But the idea should be
that not every device
should be cut off just
because it's not corp-issued.
It just maybe they can't
access really secure systems.
And then, what you get for
free when you run on us
is this idea of a
Google Front End.
And this is a
globally-distributed, near zero
latency frontend that
does a few things for you.
One is it collects all the
context of the request, the IP,
the location, the time of day.
But it also gives you lots of
things for free, if you will--
things like DDoS
protection, enforcing TLS,
the latest versions of TLS.
These are the kinds
of things that you
need any system be able
to handle and anywhere
in the world.
And then, the next
talk of this is
what we call the
Access Context Manager.
If you remember, we
talked about rules
that you should
be able to apply.
The Access Context
Manager allows
you to create
these levels, where
you can kind of pair together
these various context things.
So you can say a device
that's running only the latest
version of OS.
And coming in from this
IP address, for example,
should be able to access
my most secure systems.
Anything that's n minus 2 in
terms of OS version and maybe
doesn't need second
factor so often,
we'll allow to touch
second tier systems.
You should be able to
create rules like that
and make them mass
appliable, if you will,
to all of your systems.
Many of you have-- you
work in enterprises
where you're running
thousands, literally thousands,
of IT applications.
And you don't want take the
time to go through one by one
and tag these things.
The Access Contact Manager is
really our path to get there.
And then, you took
all this context.
You created all these rules.
And now the key is
you have to enforce it
against all of your endpoints.
I think what you'll find is we
have several solutions here,
depending on what
your use case is.
And Samuel talked
about some of these,
but I'll just briefly
touch on them.
The first one is something
called Cloud IAP,
Identity-Aware Proxy.
So if you're writing
a web application
on GCP, or in another
cloud, or on-prem,
you should be able to protect
that through these rules
that you've now defined.
You should also be able to
do that for, by the way,
SSH and TCP connections as well.
And the Identity-Aware
Proxy does exactly that.
And it does what it's clever
name tells you it does.
It really looks at the identity.
It looks at the context.
And it makes the
access decisions.
The other thing we
would allow you to do
is the same sort of thing
with our Cloud IAM system
for, think of resources.
You have a storage
bucket, let's just
say that's holding a lot
of personal information,
you can create context awareness
around access to those requests
as well.
That's just an example.
You can do all of this
with our G Suite products
through our Cloud
Identity product line.
So you can say, I want to
be able to access Gmail
at this time of day, or only
from a corporate device,
or drive, or whatever
it happens to be.
And then one of the areas
I think we really stand out
from the other vendors is what
we call VPC Service Controls.
This is the idea that
every public cloud is going
to have their APIs on the web.
That's just the
nature of a cloud.
That's, in fact, what
clouds are supposed to do.
But it's terrifying this idea
that an employee, who suddenly
goes rogue, or even
unintentionally,
takes their device
to a coffee shop
and just decides to
start shutting down
production systems.
For all the other types of
things we're talking about,
this should be the most
terrifying to most people.
And today we now we
now have a product
that's in GA that's called
the VPC Service Controls.
That allows-- that will
today take starts--
it has the beginnings
of this, but it
will start to take all
of the same context
and allow you to apply
it to public APIs.
Think of like storage buckets
and VM productions and things
like that.
You'll be able to apply
these same controls there.
And more will be
coming as we go along.
So I think it's one
thing to talk about it
and more interesting
to attempt to demo it.
So I'll have Gagan come up
and go through some demos.
[APPLAUSE]
GAGAN ARORA: Thank you, Ameet.
Hello, everyone.
My name is Gagan Arora,
and I'm a product manager
in Google Cloud.
As Ameet just touched
on, context-aware access
is the key pillar for
BeyondCorp security model.
And you all can imagine
a lot of use cases
when you think of context.
So imagine that you
want to control access
to your resources based on
where the user is coming from
or what you know about their
device, how secure that is.
There are so many use cases
that we can talk about,
but over the next
few minutes, I'm
going to go through
two specific use cases.
One on the GCP side
and one on G Suite side
to highlight how you can
enable context-aware access
in your organization.
After that, Sam is
going to come in again.
And he's going to talk about how
they are deploying Google tools
to address their use cases.
So let's look at
the use case one.
So this is something that
we heard over and over
from our customers-- that
I want to allow access
to all my applications to
users from wherever they are.
But there is an HR
application that I may have,
where I want to restrict
access to contractors only
if they are coming from
a corporate location.
So let's see how that
works in our scenario.
So since this is an
HR application on GCP,
an end user can access
this application
from wherever they are.
Now the admin wants to
enforce the use case
that we just described.
And essentially, I want
to restrict the access
based on the location
of contractors network.
So I go into Access
Context Manager,
create a rule
called access level.
And I define the contractor
IP address first.
The next thing I want to do
is, since this application is
behind the load balancer, I
want to enable IAP for this.
And this allows me
to configure who
can get access to this
application and under what
conditions.
So in this case,
I am giving access
to Bob, who is my contractor
but only if he is coming
from his corporate network.
So once I set this
rule, I can go back
and check and make sure that Bob
has access to this application.
And now we look at it
from Bob's scenario
when he is trying to
access this HR application.
So in the first scenario,
Bob is in office.
And he is logged
into his device.
And he is able to
access this application,
because he is on the
corporate network.
Now let's say, Bob
goes to a coffee shop
to get a cup of coffee.
And he tries to access
that application again.
And in that case, because he is
not from the corporate network,
he's still logged in,
but he is denied access.
So as you can see, it's
fairly easy for you
to set up these kind of
contextual rules, that
allow you to restrict access
to the applications, that
may reside on GCP, on-prem,
or any other cloud.
Now let's touch on the
case for G Suite side.
This is, again, a
fairly common scenario
that we see among
our customers, where
I am a customer with lot of
sensitive data in my Drive
and Docs.
So think of Docs, Sheets,
and anything else.
I want to make
sure that users who
are coming to access
this Drive and Docs
are coming in only if
they have a secure device.
And I'll walk you
through exactly how you
can define your version
of secure device
over the next few steps.
The first thing you need to do,
or your end users need to have,
is something called
Endpoint Verification.
It's a Chrome plugin,
that either they
can install themselves,
or you, as an admin,
can push it to their devices.
Once the end users have
Endpoint Verification installed,
as an admin, you go to your
familiar admin console.
In your security
settings, you'll
see a tab now called
Context-Aware Access.
Once you click on it, you'll
be able to set different access
levels to define the conditions.
And then you can apply them
to different resources.
So in this case, as you can
see, the corporate office
IAP that we defined
shows up here.
But we're going to define a
new rule called Secure Device.
Once you've created,
you are able to choose
different attributes
that you can
use to define what a
secure device means
for your organization.
In this case, I pick
three specific attributes.
One, I want to make sure that
any device accessing my Drive
and Docs has a password on.
Number two, I want to make sure
that the device is encrypted.
And number three,
I want to make sure
that the device is
fairly up-to-date.
And in this case, I define
that the macOS version
should be 10.0.0, which is
a fairly high version that I
want to define.
Once you create
this access level,
it's going to show up in the
list of all access levels
that you have defined.
And you can choose
other attributes like,
is their device
corporate owned or not,
is it a Chrome OS
device which I trust
and has verified access
on, and so on and so forth.
So once you have defined
the access level,
the next step is to actually go
and assign those access levels
to resources you
want to protect.
And you can do it on their
entire domain that you have,
or you can pick a
subset of users,
what we call organization
unit, and apply the same rules
to only a subset of users.
So in this case, I apply
these rules to Drive and Docs
for contractors.
And I pick that any contractor
who is accessing Drive and Docs
should be coming
with a secure device.
So once I have defined
this, any contractor
who does not meet the minimum
criteria that I have set
is not going to be able to
access the Drive and Docs that
belong to my organization.
So let's see, again, we go
back to our contractor, Bob,
who is trying to access
this application.
He does have Endpoint
Verification installed.
And this is something that sends
the device information back
to us, where we can check
for contextual information.
The next thing we check is
the OS version of the device
that Bob has.
He has a version of 10.13.6,
so this is higher than 10.0.0
that I've set.
So in this case, Bob should be
able to access Drive and Docs
when he tries to
access his documents.
Now imagine a security
vulnerability has come out.
And Apple has
released a new patch.
And you want all
your users to be
coming from this latest
patch when they're accessing
this sensitive documentation.
All you have to
do in this case is
to go back to your access
level that you defined,
update the OS version that
you defined, 10.0.0, to,
let's say, 10.14.2.
And all this happens
behind the scenes
where it gets trickled down as a
policy to all the users and all
the applications that
it was applied to.
And in this case, when Bob tries
to access the same application
again, he will be denied
access, because his OS
version, 10.13.6, is lower than
10.14.2 that you, as an admin,
require.
So as you can see,
it's fairly simple
to apply these rules across your
organization on GCP, G Suite.
You pick your
attributes and signals
that you want to
use that in context.
And then apply these rules.
We also have a live demo
running on your right side,
so feel free to go there.
And we'd love to hear
more about your use cases
and how context-aware access
can solve it for you guys.
And with that, I'll
invite Sam back.
And he's going to
talk more about IAP
and context-aware access
and how they have deployed
this to solve their use case.
[APPLAUSE]
SAMUEL KEELEY: Thank you.
So when IAP was first announced
a couple of years ago,
I was pretty excited by
it because we already
used G Suite, and
we already used
Cloud Identity for our users.
So having users that would
already integrate with this
was pretty cool
and pretty useful.
But the question was could
it help us solve our problems
with our user experience like,
making the user experience
better?
We had a pretty good grasp
on user authentication.
But just authenticating
was more than we needed.
What we really cared about
was device side as well,
especially since we've invested
so much in our endpoints
over the last three years.
So we tried other
authenticated proxies.
And I personally use some
in the past, usually labeled
as clientless VPN.
But they just kind of ended
up causing more problems
than they purported to solve.
So we needed
something different.
And that would enhance
our security and our user
experience.
With IAP working as
part of a load balancer,
it seemed to kind of fit
how modern apps work.
So setting up the context,
there were three things
that we were trying
to achieve here.
One was consistent access.
So regardless of
where somebody was,
they should be able to
access the applications
that they need to do their
job, through one easy method.
So where in the past,
we've had 802.1X, VPN,
and other methods to
get to an application,
it ends up confusing users,
where sometimes they need VPN
for something, sometimes
they need to 802.1X and VPN
for something.
And it just-- it presents a
large confusion to our users.
So we wanted consistent
access per application.
We knew that we were still going
to need VPN for some things.
But for each application, the
access should be consistent.
We wanted to enhance application
performance, especially
for users that are far
away from these apps.
So we have thousands of users
that are thousands of miles
away from the applications
that they're using.
And while it would be wonderful
if every application that we
use supported
multi-region deployments,
that's just not the
reality, especially when
we're buying third-party apps.
They might be able to work
in an HA configuration,
but they're going to
want to be deployed
all next to each other.
So we're just going to have
to pick a region for an app
to run in and deal with that.
So we want to enhance
application performance,
have the best networking
that we could.
And lastly, because security is
important, but maybe shouldn't
be the first thing on your
mind for everything out there,
is that we wanted to enforce
the endpoint security
state that we've implemented
over the past two years.
So we're really
happy with the way
that our Mac, Windows, and
Chrome OS endpoints are
managed.
But if we're not
actually enforcing
that those devices are the ones
connecting to our applications,
I don't know if there is truly
a point to us having done that.
So the first thing
that you're going
to run into if you want to
use context-aware access
is the Endpoint
Verification extension.
And the data that this
extension gives you
is incredibly powerful
and incredibly valuable.
So we actually deployed this
extension almost two years ago.
And it's been collecting
data for us ever since.
So one of the problems
that companies
run into over their growth
is that their inventory,
their physical inventory, isn't
as good as they think it is.
So when you hand a
laptop to somebody,
the first thing you're
doing when you're growing
is you're probably going
to have a spreadsheet.
And you're going to say
who you assigned it to.
And then you'll grow into some
physical inventory management
system.
But that data in there is
only as good as the data
that you put in there.
And most of that's
going to be manual.
And that doesn't scale to
having thousands and thousands
of endpoints.
So before we went and
used IAP for anything,
we rolled this extension out.
And it will tell you who's
actually using your devices.
So we force install
this extension
on all of our managed
devices and found
that definitely less
than 100% of our devices
were assigned to the people
who were actually using them.
So here's a list of my
devices that I'm using.
And some of them
are company owned.
Some of them are user owned.
And here's an example
of my MacBook Pro.
And it shows this
basic security state.
It shows company owned.
And we can use that data to
inform our physical inventory.
And we can also use that to
inform context-aware access.
So here's the thing.
We don't use GCP to
run our applications.
Like I said before,
Airbnb.com runs all on AWS.
And we have some applications
that run on-prem as well.
But IAP with context-aware was
still very appealing to us,
because our users exists on
Google, our internal users.
So how could we
achieve this when
IAP runs on the load balancer,
and the load balancer can't
target apps which
run outside of GCP?
So this is what the diagram
of this ended up looking like.
So we have our users, who talk
to the load balancer, which
goes to and talks to IAP.
And behind the load
balancer, we have just Nginx.
And we've-- yeah, so
we've set up Nginx,
and that routes the traffic all
the way back to the third-party
apps running in EC2.
So thankfully, when we built--
when we rebuilt our network
over the last few
years, we kind of
anticipated that we'd be
connecting to more than just
AWS in the future.
Now we weren't really
thinking about connecting
to other clouds.
But we knew that
we'd probably have
some like IPSec VPNs going to
vendors or something like that.
So getting a Partner
Interconnect setup
to land right next to the AWS
Direct Connect that we're using
was probably one of the
easiest parts of this project.
And the only thing that we've
had to actually deploy in GCP
is this Nginx instance,
or Nginx instances really.
But you could very well use
a different kind of proxy.
You could use Envoy
if you wanted to.
That's the cool new thing.
You could even deploy
that in Kubernetes.
But we have a lot of
familiarity with Nginx,
so we're using that.
And then, it goes over
the Partner Interconnect
and ends up back
at the application.
So that's pretty easy.
It's fairly straightforward.
Nginx just runs as
far as the traffic.
Users can get to the apps.
We can use Endpoint
Verification.
And that informs the BeyondCorp,
which acts as context manager
references.
And then we also have
Osquery and other endpoint
instrumentation, along with
our physical inventory,
talking to StreamAlert and
then talking to Lambdas,
that we've written,
that talk back to GCP,
that talk back to BeyondCorp and
inform other access decisions.
So that was for
third-party apps.
But we have a lot
of applications
that we've written internally.
And they're primarily
behind a tool
called Internal Auth, which
is an identity-aware proxy.
Long before Zero Trust and
BeyondCorp and all these words,
Airbnb built its own
authenticated proxy for this,
because we were building all
these internal applications,
but we didn't want to
rebuild authentication
every single time.
So this is in front of tools
that are Hadoop front ends
and other critical business
applications, like the launch
menu.
So this is what
Internal Auth has looked
like for a very long time.
Users come in through
VPN or 802.1X.
They come through
the Direct Connect.
And then they talk
to an Nginx proxy,
which has some middleware on it,
which authenticates to OpenLDAP
and also does MFA.
So when it authenticates
to OpenLDAP,
it gets that user's
information, which
includes their LDAP
UID and the groups
that they're a member of.
And adds those to headers,
which get passed on
to other applications, which
are running in EC2, which know
what to do with those headers.
So we wanted to rebuild this
and get the authentication
to not be LDAP-based.
We're moving towards
this new buzzword
of password-less future.
But this was still using
traditional LDAP Auth
so we're thinking like,
could we add this to SAML,
or add SAML auth to this.
But that was kind
of complicated.
So as we deployed IAP in
front of third party apps,
we kept running into
the HTTP request
headers, which come through
in every single request.
And in them, you'll see
this goog-iap-jwt-assertion,
which is this big long header.
There must be a lot
of data in there.
And what it is is
an assigned header,
which is telling you more
about what's going on.
So if we verify that
and decode that,
we can see that this is
the information contained
within the JWT.
We get the user's email.
We get their access levels,
which is really nice.
Those can be reused
in the future.
So if you want to have
your end applications maybe
make access decisions to
different types of data instead
of just access the application.
If you want to have
different regions be
able to access different
things, you can reuse this data.
But what we were really
looking at here was the email.
So this has my email in
it, but that's not really
what we needed.
What we needed was the
LDAP UID and the groups.
We wanted to deploy this
without making any changes
to the applications.
So this is what
we ended up doing.
This is what we've been working
on over the last few weeks
actually.
So this is a little bit
different from last time.
It's a little bit simplified.
I'm not including the full
access context manager path.
But we can see here
that IAP adds this HTTP
header to the requests.
And now, since the user is
already logged in through IAP,
our middleware has
been much simplified.
So instead of the middleware
authenticating the user,
it's just going to
OpenLDAP to take that email
and resolve it to an LDAP UID
and get the same user and group
information that we always
had to pass it along
to those applications.
So we still have a very similar
deployment as we've had.
But users get a much
simplified experience,
because they're
already logged in.
And they're not having
to log in a second time.
Our MFA is simplified.
And we're able to bypass VPN and
802.1X for these applications.
So to wrap up my
part, I have to say
that not everything
is perfect with IAP
and context-aware right now.
So this is a pleading face.
So this is everything
that I plead
to Ameet about that
I've been promised
is going to be
fixed in the future.
So non-GCP backend support,
the way we're doing with Nginx,
is kind of a hack.
I mean, Nginx is a known
beast, but I don't really
want to run those anymore.
So in the future,
GCP load balancers
are going to support
network endpoint groups.
So they support network
endpoint groups--
I think it was in
beta as of recently.
It might be GA now.
But what we really need
is network endpoint groups
to be hybrid so we can
target things outside of GCP.
And that would allow
us to get rid of Nginx.
It would make deploying
this way easier.
This is a big sticking point.
Chrome is the only
supported browser for--
supported desktop browser
for Endpoint Verification.
So if you have users using
Safari, or Firefox, or Edge,
and you want to verify any
of their endpoint states,
it's just not going to work.
They're not going to
have access today.
iOS and Android support,
not yet generally available.
But I've been told
it will be beta soon.
For third party apps,
because the session time
of IAP sessions
is only one hour,
if you're using AJAX
apps, the callbacks
will start to fail
after an hour.
If you write your own apps,
you can do session refreshing
yourself.
But if you're using
third party apps,
you're probably going to
need to inject an iframe
into those applications.
Nginx is really good at that.
That's what we're doing,
but that's a headache
that you'll probably run into.
And then applications that might
have a mix of thick clients
and web clients that might
hit the same endpoints
are going to be really
hard to deal with.
But not everything is terrible.
I want to leave you with
some things that I do like.
So oh, they're all
appearing at once.
But if a web application
can live behind a web--
oh, no.
There is a missing
smiley face there.
If a web app can live
behind a load balancer,
it's probably going to be
really easy to use IAP with it.
And the Google Front
End really helps us
with having performant
access to these apps.
The session initiation
is really fast.
And the premium
network is definitely
better than the
general internet.
So when we have users
coming from very far,
it helps us a lot.
And then the information that we
get in the JWTs is very useful.
And I'm very excited about the
future state of context-aware
for IAP, G Suite, and SAML
so we have consistent access
to everything.
AMEET JANI: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]